Hello, Matthew Lucas.
It's Pastry Week!
Are you excited? Yes, I am excited.
For I have here a shoe pastry.
But I very much hope I don't
get the laces stuck in my teeth.
Welcome to
The Great British Bake Off.
Mmm, nice.
Last time...
Why is it falling?
..the bakers battled
Bavarian delicacies.
Oh, no!
While Jurgen got off to
a strong start...
You've done well there, Jurgen.
..it was Giuseppe
who claimed the German crown.
It's delicious. I think
you've done an amazing job.
And with a soggy Showstopper...
Wonder if I overdid the wine.
..Freya became the latest baker
to leave the tent.
It's only vegan chocolate cake!
Now...
Just wanna give it a little love.
..the bakers tackle pastry.
Can I just say I think you've
invented like a new dance move here?
Do you think?
..as it's fried...
I feel like I'm having
heart palpitations.
..folded... Filo pastry.
Never made it in my life.
..and filled.
Can't tell what's sausage
and what's hands,
to be honest with you.
Who will perfect pastry?
Oh, it collapsed.
I can't watch.
I know. it's too stressful.
And who has baked their last?
Have you seen this here?
This is week six.
The second half of the journey.
I'm performing much better
than I expected.
In fact,
I have to keep buying shirts
cos I didn't bring enough
with me.
I've managed to worm my way through
cos there's been loads of people,
but now it's getting less,
it's harder.
I spoke to Lizzie and I was like,
"Come on, Lizzie, we cannot back
down.
"We've got to do it for Freya,
"like, come on, like,
the women have got to do it."
I think Amanda might be able
to pull it out of the bag.
I think pastry week's her week.
No-one's given up in there.
I'm certainly not giving up.
Hello, bakers,
welcome back to the tent.
It's Pastry Week.
It's time for your
Signature Challenge.
Paul and Prue
would like you each to make
two batches of decorated chouxnuts.
Did you know that
Paul Hollywood invented
the chouxnut pouch?
He had some spare leather
and nowhere to put his nuts.
No, you're thinking of
the jock strap, Noel. Oh, yeah.
Now, your chouxnuts
need to be perfectly fried.
Six filled, six not filled.
And either glazed or iced.
You have two hours.
On your marks.
Get set.
Uh, uh, uh, wait, Chigs.
Cos I haven't said it yet.
LAUGHTER
Not my time you're wasting.
Bake!
A chouxnut is much lighter
than a doughnut.
It's almost like a fried eclair.
I actually prefer the chouxnut
to doughnuts.
Yeah. I like eating them.
I'm not a choux-nutter, at all.
I mean, if I went to hell, I feel
like this is what my hell would be.
If you've never heard of
a chouxnut before,
basically it's choux pastry
piped into a doughnut shape,
deep-fried.
We want two batches.
One of them has
to have filling inside
and one of them has to have
a really interesting icing
or glaze.
The chouxnuts themselves
are quite aerated.
You want that beautiful aeration
inside the chouxnut.
Choux has to be exactly
the right consistency.
So getting the paste right
is most important.
If it's too wet,
it's going to sink.
Morning, Lizzie. Morning.
Right, Lizzie, chouxnuts.
Chouxnuts.
Oh, the devil's doughnuts.
They have me shook already.
I'm like shaken.
What she's saying is
she's quite upset about it.
LAUGHTER
So tell us about your flavours.
So I'm doing raspberry liqueur
and hibiscus
for the filled one.
OK. Oh, lovely. OK. That sounds
absolutely delicious.
Lizzie's raspberry liqueur
and hibiscus-filled chouxnuts
will be paired with
a caramel-glazed unfilled batch.
But she's more confident with
her flavours than with the fryer.
So why have you found this
to be a problem?
I just hate choux pastry
and I just feel like
the fryer's gonna like hit me
and I'm gonna burn.
Feels like you're in a chippy,
doesn't it? God, yeah.
The pressure is just unbelievable.
Even my elbows are sweating.
Your elbows are sweating? Yeah.
Never heard about sweaty elbows.
Good name for a punk band,
that, the Sweaty Elbows.
It's going to be fine.
Oh, hopefully.
Lizzie might be dreading
the fryer,
but one baker
couldn't be more excited.
Gorgeous. Can you smell
that frying oil?
Can't wait to make this. Yummy.
OK, so one I'm doing
a classic sticky toffee.
I'm making a really easy toffee
just because of
the time pressure in here.
And it's also all about
my pastry today.
George is keeping
his flavours simple
with one toffee-glazed choux batch
and another filled with
jam and cream.
Today he's focusing on his flavours
to impress Paul and Prue.
Tell us about the pastry.
Um, I, I just wanted to get
a nice airy dough.
Poker face.
Look at George's
questioning eyes,
"Is that OK?" Getting nothing.
You're not doing this to me,
Paul.
Perfect choux is light and airy,
characterised by large holes
on the inside.
We fold air in and then just
give it a really good mix.
Egg is vital
to bind the ingredients,
helping it to puff up when fried.
This is the bit that
can go wrong the most
out of the whole process
cos if you add too many eggs,
the batter becomes runny and you
will not be able to shape it.
It's a fine line.
More egg means more liquid
which could lead to chouxnuts
that are as flat as a pancake.
You kind of have to do this by eye.
Um, and obviously baking
is all about precision.
You should be able to pick it up
and it drips into a V.
Yeah. Done.
But Chigs' dough isn't done.
I'm making a chocolate dough.
That one will be a little bit
tougher because of the cocoa powder.
So I will add a bit more egg in.
I just need to be careful with it.
His chocolate pastry
will form his unfilled chouxnut,
topped with a lime glaze.
But Chigs is the only baker
braving two different pastries.
His plain batch will be filled
with hazelnut praline,
evoking the French classic
the Paris-Brest.
Right, I'm gonna start making pastry
for the Paris-Brest flavour.
The what, sorry? Paris-Brest.
Parry Brea... what?
Yes, that's right.
It's got breasts in it?
Too much for my head.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
EXHALES
Look at Jurgen's stance.
Yes, action stance.
There's a lot to do.
Come on, come on.
While Chigs races to finish
his second batch of pastry,
the rest of the bakers
have bagged theirs up...
Done. Right, I'm just gonna make
my glaze.
..and are pushing on with
their toppings and fillings.
Time for Italian alcohol.
Er, I thought it would have been
unacceptable
for an Italian
to come on Bake Off
and not use limoncello somewhere,
and this seemed to be
the right excuse to get some in
the ingredients list.
Giuseppe's bringing the taste of
Italy to his chouxnuts
with a filled batch packed
with limoncello liqueur
and the other topped
with almond nougatine.
I'm making both batches
with standard flavours
I'm most familiar with, you know,
to play it safe and to do,
to go with something
that I knew already.
But one baker who isn't
playing it safe is Crystelle.
I wanted something
completely different
so I've gone for miso caramel,
salty sweet chouxnut.
Hopefully it works.
Er, it shouldn't taste
of miso soup, I hope.
A passion fruit
and mango-filled choux
will sit alongside another
glazed in a novel miso caramel.
Tell me about the miso.
I feel like miso caramel's
kind of like just a step up
from salted caramel.
So miso's quite umami.
You kind of get this salty
umami undertone.
"Lovely umami undertone."
LAUGHTER
No more middle class-sentence
has ever been uttered.
That's not something
you'd hear every day.
Right, thanks, Noel.
But Crystelle isn't the only baker
riding the sweet and savoury trend.
This one's going to be glazed
with maple syrup
with some bacon on the top.
It's delicious.
Amanda's planning to pair
her maple and bacon glazed chouxnut
with another batch
filled with pistachio and rose.
What sweet and savoury mixes
could we invent?
Jam and sausage?
Jam sausage?
What about chocolate onion?
Probably not. No, I'm not liking
the sound of that one.
No. Sweet and savoury's a terrible
idea. Yeah, whose idea was that?
When it comes to
weird and wonderful flavours,
Jurgen's pushing the boat out
even further.
This is ube extract
from a purple Filipine yam
which has a vanilla-y,
quite unique flavour.
Also the colour
should be stunning.
He's making a yuzu
and sake glazed choux
to pair with his ube-filled batch,
the bright colours
mimicking pastries
he ate as a child in the '70s.
Well, that's an amazing colour.
On top of the purple colour
the glaze will be orange
as well.
LAUGHTER All right, Jurgen,
we'll look forward to
your '70s psychedelic dyes.
You've already won for me.
That colour's so strong.
Right, I'm just trying to completely
make sure they're fried.
Do you fry a lot?
No, no. No.
I don't own one of them at home.
No, I don't. I own two.
Ha-ha.
Bakers, you have half an hour.
No pressure.
I'm sure it'll be fine.
Just piping my choux dough
nicely and gently.
Paul and Prue are expecting
uniform chouxnuts...
I'm making sure the shape
is as consistent as possible.
..fried to perfection.
Fryers scare me.
I'm literally shaking.
Lizzie? Yeah.
Don't worry. Have confidence.
Let's go, let's go.
Each fried chouxnut needs to be
crunchy on the outside,
light and fluffy in the middle.
You don't know
when chouxnuts are done.
No-one knows.
I'm sure one of these knows.
They need at least five minutes
otherwise they will then
collapse afterwards.
Not only is the frying time
critical,
the oil temperature
must also be correct.
I'm aiming for 175.
Nice and hot.
Just want a little bit of brown
on the edge.
Achieving the perfect chouxnut
is no mean feat
when the bakers still have
toppings to prepare.
Ridiculous - still making the glaze
for the chocolate ones.
So many elements.
I feel like I'm having
heart palpitations.
Multi-tasking is a bit of
a challenge. Right...
Oh, see, look, I didn't start
the bloody timer.
My last... It's fine, it's fine.
I'll, I'll just hope and pray.
Maybe I'll do two minutes.
These tongs are hot.
Ooh!
How do you open this thing?
Hmm?
Push it in.
OK.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes left.
Come on.
That's exactly what I wanted
to get.
Seems to be a good golden colour.
Shame about the light colour.
But never mind.
I can't even look at you,
you're making me sweat more.
What, in the elbows?
Yeah. Maybe I've got issues.
Right, filling.
♪ You've got to pump it up... ♪
The filled chouxnuts
must be crammed full of cream.
Crucial moment.
But the more they inject,
the more chance of an explosion.
Oh, my God, it's all coming out.
What?
Jeez.
So this is the last
filled chouxnut.
Why is so much coming out?
Oops.
OK, passion juice
in the crinkly ball.
The crinkly ball, the passion juice
comes out. Yeah, it's quite nice.
I like that. It is nice.
Limoncello. This is gonna be
a very, very close call.
How long we got left now?
One minute left.
Oh, no, oh, no.
Rush at the end.
They're nearly done.
Come on. There's no time
to waste!
Bakers, your time is up.
Can you stop touching your nuts,
please?
George! I'm eating it.
Don't touch any of your nuts.
I'm not touching.
Lizzie, will you try
any of your nuts?
Absolutely not.
They are horrible.
I think they're a bit soggy.
They're just underfried.
A rookie error in this competition,
just not setting the timer.
The bakers' chouxnuts will now face
the judgment of Paul and Prue.
Hello, George.
Hello, George. Hi, hiya.
You've got a
nice robust mixture there
which has given you that pop.
This is a toffee and hazelnut
chouxnut. These are not filled.
Mm.
Toffee-ish, really nutty.
Goes nicely with the soft choux.
Delicious. Lovely.
Let's have a
look at your filled one.
It's got a Chantilly cream with
raspberry jam rippled through.
You've given me an empty bit.
It's important you get the filling
right the way round. Yeah.
Quite often I need two holes
so that I can squirt.
You squeeze the bag. Yeah.
When you meet that
little bit of resistance,
it usually means it's full.
STIFLED LAUGHTER
Why are you laughing?
We're just children.
You're grown up.
Sorry, Dame Prue.
Exactly. Stop this nonsense.
Tell him it's lovely.
I think when you do... Sorry.
I think when you do get the cream
filling and the jam, it's delicious.
Thank you.
The filled ones
have an ube creme pat.
That ube colour is just
extraordinary, isn't it?
That slightly vanillary ube
taste is... unusual,
but sort of vaguely familiar.
I think the, the structure on that
is very good.
It's nice and open. It's very light.
It's so delicate it's lovely. OK.
These are the unfilled ones.
They have a yuzu and sake glaze.
It has that little bit of acidity
which yuzu gives it.
They're both delicious. Thank you.
The filled ones,
they are Paris-Brest inspired.
I've got a praline
cream in the middle.
Can't really see the structure,
cos there's so much of the filling!
I think Paris-Brest should have
lots of filling.
That's delicious. Mm.
This is my chocolate lime chouxnut.
The cocoa, that's just enough
to marry with the lime. Yeah.
It's unusual, but it does work.
It's a nice chouxnut, that one.
Thank you.
It's delicate.
So, those are the empty chouxnuts
with an almond praline.
Good frying.
Colour's nice, isn't it?
The contrast of the praline crunch
and the softness of the choux
is just lovely.
OK. Let's have a look at your filled
one. Creme pat and limoncello.
It's definitely creme pat
with limoncello!
There is too much limoncello -
and I can't resist another mouthful.
Aha! Mm.
This is the miso... caramel.
And white chocolate, yeah.
It is exactly how you said.
It's umami.
It's got... you know it has got
that bitterness to it. Mm-hm.
And the tropical passion fruit
choux is just beautiful.
But the choux itself... Mm.
..is very tight.
Yeah. It's not open enough.
It should be, "pff".
You've lost a lot of the definition.
Do you think you lost some of the
definition in the frying? Yeah.
You need to give it a bit of a...
Yeah... hit.
The choux's let you down
a little bit. OK, thank you.
OK. The maple bacon.
It needs the bacon.
Could've done with a tiny bit more.
Yeah - that's a shame,
cos I had so much left over. Yeah.
Well, let's have a
look at your filled one.
It's pistachio creme pat
with a rose glaze.
The, uh, rose, it's like, artificial
cordial. Too rosy and too sweet. OK.
Quite attractive.
The frying colour looks good.
Mm.
Hibiscus and what?
Raspberry liqueur.
The hibiscus flavour's quite nice
and so's the raspberry.
Overall it's got a nice
structure to it.
It's delicate, and the
toffee is delicious, as well.
I would buy these in a shop.
That's for sure.
Thank you, I've been in panic.
You're ruining my lifetime's theory
that you cannot cook
if you don't love it.
Well done. Thank you. Anyway,
well done. Ta. Well done. Ta.
Feel so sick.
Great stuff, well done.
That was my best Signature feedback.
I thought I was gonna, like, pass
out when they were speaking to me.
I just couldn't believe what
they were saying.
I don't think they were overly
enamoured with the rose flavour,
but that's OK.
Gotta try these things, haven't you?
My choux pastry wasn't up to
scratch, and it's Pastry Week -
but I'm gonna have to try and pull
it out of the bag in the Technical.
I just need to tell myself I have a
functioning brain
and hopefully my brain'll function
and I will do a Technical Challenge
successfully.
The bakers were able to
practise their chouxnuts,
but have no idea what awaits them
in the Technical Challenge.
Bakers, welcome back to the tent
for your Technical Challenge,
which today has been
set by Holly Paulwood.
Holly, any words of advice?
This particular recipe
will push you to your limits.
Don't waste any time.
Thank you, Holly, and may I say
you're looking gorgeous tonight?!
Now, as ever, the Technical
Challenge will be judged blind,
so we're gonna have to ask Holly
and Prue to leave the tent.
Off you pop.
The judges would love you to make
a large baklava with filo pastry.
Oh, no! Oh, man.
Your filo pastry should be made
using a traditional
laminating technique
layered with a pistachio
and walnut filling
and cut into a star design.
You have 2 hours and 45 minutes.
On your marks. Get set. Bake!
Oh, Jesus.
Filo pastry is
notoriously complicated.
Filo pastry?
Never made it in my life.
Who makes their own filo pastry?
No-one.
This is the first time ever the
bakers have been asked to make it
for a Technical Challenge.
I've never attempted filo.
Or baklava.
I really wish that
I had spent more time in the kitchen
with my Greek grandmother.
Let's just be confident
that it's in my DNA.
You thought, you've got two Greeks
in the tent,
they're bound to know
how to make it.
Paul, I think this must be the most
difficult Technical I've ever seen.
Yeah. Baklava.
The hardest part is the lamination.
Above all you've gotta get
that flake.
There's three layers
and then you have the nut layer
and then three layers again.
You've gotta make your dough
and divide it into six.
Three for the bottom,
three for the top.
Then fold it, fold it,
fold it, fold it.
You've gotta do that six times.
Times six.
So, there's a lot of layers
by the time we've finished. Yeah.
If they haven't laminated it, you're
gonna get a solid piece of dough.
You're not gonna get that
beautiful filo pastry. Layered.
Which is what we're gonna be
looking for. OK, let's cut a slice.
Well, that looks beautiful,
thank you.
Who is really gonna come up
trumps in the tent?
I have no idea,
cos this is complicated.
I'm gonna tell myself I can do it,
because I have to,
because otherwise I'm going home -
and I refuse to go home.
First step is for the filo pastry.
Put the dry ingredients into a bowl,
then combine with wet ingredients.
Two eggs, vegetable oil, some butter
and some white wine vinegar.
Full fat Greek yoghurt, as well.
Greek yoghurt.
There you go.
I suppose the yoghurt is in there
because it's a Greek recipe!
Hello. Hey, Matt.
So, have you made baklava before?
I've never made baklava before.
I've never made filo pastry before.
You haven't? It's a massive hassle.
Why would you? Just buy it.
It's a what? A massive...? Hassle.
Oh, "hass". Hassle. Hassle. Hassle.
Oh, my word! I genuinely thought you
said something else there.
A massive hassle. Please don't
write in to complain. Hassle.
Right, let's get my hands in there.
Right, gonna knead the hell
out of this.
I don't want to have too
much gluten in here.
Just enough that it holds together.
And now I'm out of breath.
I think you've invented, like,
a new dance move here. Do you think?
Any other moves? So there's this
one which is kind of. Yeah.
It's called the side shuffle. OK.
And then you've got, like,
the little...
The slam. The slam. Yeah.
I've got a good one, which is...
Go on... the taste.
Where you go like this.
It's underproved.
I'm just doing it
cos other people are doing it!
Don't know what it does.
Right, it's gotta go six
equal balls now.
Dough feels very soft.
It's pretty good.
Roll out the balls of dough to a
square approximately 30 centimetres.
The key part of baklava
is having the layers,
really thin, crispy pastry.
Fold the top and bottom into the
centre creating a rough square.
Take each corner and fold into
the middle. Dust with cornflour.
This is laminating to create
layers in filo.
To create the multi layers of flaky
pastry baklava is famous for...
Corner to corner.
..the bakers must intricately fold
and roll the dough
in a process called lamination.
So I'm taking the edges
to the centre.
Usually you create layers using fat
but in this instance
we're using cornflour.
Hmm, I don't know if this is right.
Like that?
Great, I've gotta do that
six times now.
One, two, three, four.
Folding the edges. Dust.
Now we're talking!
Last one.
Cover and rest,
so I'm covering it and resting it.
I'm measuring out
my pistachio kernels.
The filling needs to provide
that crunchy texture.
I might give them a haircut.
Are you gonna mess this one up like
you did this morning?
I... What? Ohh!
Oh-ee! You're so bloody rude.
Hello, this is the talking cupcake
saying you are halfway
through the challenge.
I glued that there while
you were asleep. Oh, no. Did you?
To assemble, roll the dough
into six 30 centimetre circles,
stack in the tin.
Rolling it back out. Again.
Right that's layer one.
Right, two of six.
This is a bit of a dodgy layer.
Next is the filling.
You want a fair bit of filling -
don't want a stingy baklava, do you?
Now I'm gonna be rolling out
the other three discs.
Cover it up and then proceed
with the next steps.
Don't panic, and follow the recipe.
That's done, everything's done.
Using the diagram provided,
cut the pastry into a star design.
Of course the diagram is smaller.
How are you meant to do this?
There must be an easier way
than this.
Pretty clear, isn't it?
It's actually scaled up.
This one is 20 centimetres wide.
This is 30 centimetres wide.
Oh, he's just showing off.
Do I cut all the way through
or do I just put it on the top?
Who are you talking to?
Are you talking to me? I'm...
You're talking to God!
Noel, do you think I...
Do I cut all the way through it?
Do I cut this all the way through?
I'm gonna cut all the way through.
Go through the worktop into hell
where Paul Hollywood lives.
Me pattern's gone mental.
Don't know what I'm doing any more.
It's hurting my eyes to look at it
so I'm just free styling.
What is that? There's too many
lines for me.
Right, have I done it?
Yeah, I've done it.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Ugh, I'll have to eyeball it, innit?
I don't know how long pastry takes.
40 minutes baking.
This train is due to arrive at the
end of the challenge in 30 minutes.
I think I'm just
going to rotate this.
Bit more butter.
It looks like it's drying out
a little bit.
Just wanna give it a little love.
Oh, come on.
I don't suppose this is one of those
that you can test
with a toothpick, is it?
I think me timer
was set for, like...
Oh, my God.
I didn't put the timer on.
Can't remember how long
it's been in the oven.
How long have we got left?
You have ten minutes left.
It looks done to me.
Ah. What do I do?
I'm gonna go for it now.
I'm taking it out, I'm taking
it out, I'm taking it out.
Agh.
It's a little bit anaemic.
It has pretty much the right colour.
Right, baklava is soaked in syrup.
Syrupy. There we go.
Syrup's gone on. Yum!
Ground pistachios.
So, there's a diamond.
I'm gonna freehand it.
Oh, I'm not sure about this.
The patterns are not
making sense to me.
It's just too much for my mind to
think of a template, to be honest.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
Come on!
It's not coming off.
Ooh.
Last little bit, rose petals.
Shaking like there was no tomorrow.
Come on.
Come on!
Oh, it's so hot.
Almost.
Bakers, your time is up.
That was not pleasant.
That seems really soggy.
Terrified.
Paul and Prue are looking
for seven beautiful baklava
with striking layers of laminated
filo pastry -
but they have no idea
whose is whose.
Shall we start over here,
then, Prue?
The colour's quite nice.
I quite like the colour.
The colour's lovely.
Let's see what it's like.
It's not that bad.
You can see a bit of lamination
there. Yeah. A little bit there.
Mm, really nice -
and if you saw that in a pastry shop
you'd buy a bit, wouldn't you? Mm.
Moving on.
Quite a lot of...
Bit too much pistachio... pistachio.
Little bit too much.
Very clumsy at the edge.
It is - you want it to be
more delicate.
It's sort of, yeah, oh, that'll do.
You can see the lamination
on the top. Yeah.
But you want it a little
darker in colour.
It needed longer in the oven.
Mm, that's lovely flavour.
OK. This is nice and shiny.
I do like the colour of this one.
And the cut is nice.
You have lamination there, see.
Yeah, it's nice and crisp on the
bottom. Mm. The flavour's good.
Moving on. The design's quite
nice on this. Yeah. Neat.
But it's a little undercooked.
It needs longer.
And it's such a pity, cos there's
lots and lots of layers in there.
Yeah, OK.
You can't really see the diamonds.
You've lost all the shape
and all the cut.
It's mess, the top of that's a mess.
This is deliberately to... Mask it.
..to mask the fact that the pattern
has been lost.
The syrup's nice.
There is lamination, it's just
quite doughy. Needed longer.
Moving on.
This is beautiful.
It's a nice design. Very nice.
All the way around.
Yeah, it's got good
lamination there.
It's got a nice colour. Yeah,
it's got good lamination on the top.
Mm, that is lovely crisp,
really good. Mm.
Last. A little bit
higgledy-piggledy, these.
It is a bit all over the place,
innit?
Where are the nuts?
Ah, I had to cut in
to see where they were.
The layers are quite thick.
But the flavour's nice. Delicious.
OK, this is gonna be very
difficult judging.
Paul and Prue will now rank the
baklava from last to first place.
In seventh spot we have this one.
Lizzie, comes down to that little
bit of finesse that you need.
I just haven't got finesse.
You have.
PRUE CHUCKLES
In sixth spot we have this one.
George, just a little bit clumsy.
Amanda is fifth,
Giuseppe fourth, and Chigs is third.
In second place... we have this one.
Oh, my God!
Well, it looks absolutely beautiful.
Well done.
In first we have...
APPLAUSE
Can't believe it!
The diamond pattern
on the top is very good.
You've got a beautiful colour all
the way through. Well done, Jurgen.
Thank you. Smashed it again, mate.
Well done.
What a day. Incredible.
Jurgenator seems to be back!
Oh, my God!
I'm in so much shock -
and do you know what?
I really needed that today.
I've never been up there in
the Technical, so, feels quite wild.
I could've done a lot better
but I had a pretty good Signature -
but I'm not gonna kind of write
myself off just yet.
This rain pretty much symbolises
how my Technical went.
It was a disaster.
Tomorrow I've just got to
do the best I can.
Just one challenge remains
in pastry week.
It's quite wet out there.
The rain is pretty deafening
but we're going to carry on.
Of course. So far,
they're pretty good, actually.
You got Chigs, Giuseppe, you got
Jurgen and you got Crystelle,
you know in the sort of top four
of this week overall.
I think when it comes to the people
that have struggled over
the two challenges, Amanda
and Lizzie, those two...
Where's George, is he in the middle?
I think he's in the middle again,
yeah. A remake of
Malcolm In The Middle over here...
You know what, though?
It's not a bad place to be. But I've
been on Bake Off five years now
and occasionally someone does
something and you almost cry
because it's overwhelmingly good.
You're almost moved. Yes.
Yeah, OK, we want one of those,
guys. We want one of those today.
That's what we're after.
Hello, bakers,
welcome back to the tent.
It's time for your
Showstopper Challenge.
Today the judges would love you
to make an intricate terrine pie.
In the grand old tradition
of French pate en croute,
the judges would like your
showstopping terrine pies
to have an ornate pastry
decoration on the outside.
And to reveal a neat pattern
or design when the pie is cut open.
The fillings and flavours
are up to you.
Noel, what flavours would you use?
I think I'd make a hip-hop
terrine pie.
It'd probably be Flava Flav flavour.
I've just seen Flava Flav's
big clock, actually,
and it seems you've got
four and a half hours
to complete your
Showstopper Challenge.
On your marks. Get set.
♪ Don't believe the hype! ♪
And bake.
The terrine pie originated in France
and is typically packed
with a meat pate.
This is the perfect weather
for a warm pie.
All we need now is a nice glass
of port and a fireplace.
I think this is one of my favourite
challenges because I get to cook.
I'm excited to make it.
I have got thyme on my hands.
We're looking for a highly
decorative terrine.
Now, we're looking for
a decoration on the top
and a beautiful pattern inside.
And I've a little pattern.
Do need finesse today.
The most obvious thing that could go
wrong is they run out of time.
Cos when you bake it, you then need
a decent length of time
to cool it enough to cut it.
This is going to be a very, very
close call
to get it cooled down and set.
Leaking and collapsing
are my biggest fears.
You've got to set everything.
If it's cooler, whatever filling
they've got in will tend to congeal
and solidify and allow that slice
to fall without falling to pieces.
Hi, Jurgen. What are you doing
for your terrine?
Uh, I'm making Lunch in Freiburg.
Freiburg, my hometown,
has a famous dish which it's topside
of beef with horseradish
and sauerkraut. Oh, lovely. Wow, OK.
And all of that goes into my pie.
You can't go wrong with horseradish
and a bit of beef. No.
Jurgen's transforming Freiburg's
famous beef dish
into an ornate pie,
featuring a colourful square
running through the centre
and a border of plaited pastry.
I must say, it sounds absolutely
delicious. Does sound good.
Can you get some German beer ready
for me as well, please?
Ah, unfortunately,
I didn't bring any.
THEY LAUGH
Starting to make my hot water crust.
It's a lot of lard.
No lard before Marbs.
Hot water crust is a go-to pastry
when making savoury pies.
You add hot water into the fat
and flour to gelatinize it.
The addition of hot water
gives the dough elasticity.
There's no danger of it...
I don't really want to say this.
..of it cracking.
But speed is of the essence.
You have to work
with it while it's warm.
So it's kind of race against time.
The faster they work,
the more pliable the pastry.
Need to do this quick enough
to help it stay like Play-Doh
so I don't tear it. And if they can
rush out the rip-free shell...
Fridge... they'll have more time
to work on the filling.
And George isn't wasting any time
cracking on with his.
This is pretty much like
a Christmas dinner in a pie.
We've got sausage meat,
need to roll it bacon,
and then I've got to do...
I've got a lot to do.
We should stop talking. One second.
He's going all out
with his Christmas dinner pie.
The exterior will feature
a decorative pastry print,
the interior a duck
and turkey stuffing
and a giant bacon
and carrot wrapped sausage.
All right, getting there,
getting there.
This is my big massive sausage.
Can't tell what's sausage and what's
hands, to be honest with you.
HE LAUGHS
That's why I love you.
You're out of order.
Amanda's also shaping a sausage.
I do love to make my food with love.
So my sausage is beautifully
presented with bacon,
cherries and pistachios.
She aims to showcase her love
of gourmet food
with a pretty pate pie,
featuring her striking
chicken pate sausage,
a floral decoration and pork pigs.
My sausage is done
so I'm making my little piggies.
There's one.
Lizzie's also aiming
to serve a feast for the eyes.
I am making potato fishes.
It's gonna be unusual.
I want to be the Heston Blumenthal
of the tent.
She hopes to banish the memory
of her messy Technical
with a jaw-dropping Neptune Pie.
The top features a flamboyant
mermaid tail
and the centre,
her novel potato fish.
You're not panicking today?
You seem a bit calmer.
No, I'm a lot calmer today.
Like, I've practised this a couple
of times. It was quite funny
at home. It was like Where's Wally
but with the fish. Everyone was
like, "Have I found the fish yet?"
And I was like, you're just meant
to be able to see it!
THEY LAUGH
Animal designs are proving
a popular choice in the tent.
I've decided to decorate it as
an owl cos it's my wife's
favourite animal.
Um, and she's been incredibly
supportive in all of this.
And she's a much better baker
than I am.
Giuseppe hopes his wife
Laura love both the owl
and the interior which will include
three colourful fillings -
a circle of beef, spinach
and smoked mozzarella.
Lovely finger action you've got.
I know.
Do you think this is good enough for
my wife? Yeah, perfect. Thank you.
Giuseppe might want to wow his wife
but Crystelle's out to impress
her entire family.
Today's bake is dedicated
to my late, great grandmother
called Lila Nana. It's a curry. I
learnt how to make it from my mum.
Do you know what? This is, for me,
I think, my most sentimental bake.
Um, it's a family thing so, for me,
it's just... I really want to do
my family proud with this recipe.
An ode to her late,
great grandmother,
the pie will be shaped to mimic
Lily Nana's Kenyan cottage
and layered with two
of her home recipes -
potato curry and a Goan chicken
pickle curry.
But with a high liquid content,
Crystelle's risking a runny pie.
Getting a curry which is
usually just dumped on a plate
in a rectangular pie was tricky.
Is it going to remain fairly stable?
We don't want to cut in
and it just floods out.
But if it's a really good curry,
as it cools it'll get solid.
It should set slightly.
Exactly that.
Well, good luck,
this sounds amazing. Oh, thank you.
I'd quite like to move in.
Yeah, I would, yeah,
I'd move straight into that.
I hope it turns out OK. Thank you.
Don't want chicken curry
splashing all over you.
Crystelle might be concerned
her curry's too moist...
Oh, BLEEP.
Why's it so stiff?
..but George's giant sausage
is rock hard. Guys.
It's a bit frozen. Put it in
the freezer, I forgot about it.
God, I can't give Prue and Paul
food poisoning.
Bakers, you have three hours left!
You know when I said,
quick, let's do a time call?
I didn't mean let's do a time call
really quickly. But I liked it.
Feeling a bit overwhelmed. I think
I'm going to leave it five minutes.
While George worries about his
sausage, the rest of the bakers
can begin the build.
The last thing you want is
a soggy bottom so I'm using ham.
To stop any liquid.
Stopping a soggy bottom
is just the start.
Paul and Prue are expecting
a beautiful interior...
OK. Potato fishes.
So the fish is going to be, like,
floating in the pattern.
..each slice crammed with
mouthwatering ingredients.
Right, do it for Lily Nana.
Goan cuisine is going in.
Lots of different flavours.
But Chigs has just
one thing on his mind.
Me, I've got some pork
shoulder, pork neck.
This is a pork fest.
Chigs' Leicester Pork Pie.
HE LAUGHS
He's honouring his home county
Leicestershire,
famed for the Melton Mowbray
pork pie.
The centre will be enhanced
with a smattering of colour,
the top a lattice decoration.
Leicestershire is renowned for pork
pies so I hope I do 'em proud.
OK, decoration. This is the fastest
I'm ever going to work.
I'm hoping to bake soon.
I've made chimneys for the steam.
Now crucial moment.
OK. Come on, Crystelle.
Please work.
Trying to figure out how long
to bake cos got to give enough time
to basically cool it down as well.
Now timing is critical.
On top of baking, the bakers must
factor in chilling.
It's all a balancing act because
I want the whole thing fully cooked.
Also I'm going to need a long
cooling time after the baking
because I need to make sure
that the inside is set and
it doesn't collapse.
A good bake will count for nothing
if the pie falls apart.
I've got two hours left.
I need 40 minutes
to whack it in the fridge
so hopefully it'll be done
in 80 minutes.
Oh, fingers crossed.
But George needs more than luck
to fix his time keeping.
The sausage is in but I'm late.
Just rolling decorations on top.
Come on, come on, come on.
Freaking out.
And he isn't the only baker
who's fallen behind.
I've probably spent a bit more time
on decorating than I do normally.
It's my favourite bit, decorating.
I like to make things look nice.
Do you know what? My husband
gets a bit impatient
because I want to decorate 'em.
He just wants to eat the pie.
Just says,
"Get the pie in the oven."
Jesus, now what have I done?
Think I was a bit heavy
with the egg wash.
Don't have time for this.
I need to move now.
Done.
Why is it already leaking?
It hasn't even gone in the oven.
Leaking or not...
Just making all my decoration.
I am worried about the pie, though.
..all the bakers can do now is wait.
Yours is leaking.
Your dough's not leaking.
It is leaking. Can't you smell it?
This is getting stressful.
I should've brought a book.
George, what do you normally do
while you're waiting for something
to bake? What about your dancing?
What dancing? Tell Matt.
Oh, do you do Greek dancing?
No. Amanda.
We'll do it with you. I'm not doing
it. Quick, quick, quick.
Just a bit worried about my pie.
Come on, George.
She's the teacher. She knows it.
Well, go on, what is it? Go on,
then, Amanda. Right, teach Matt.
Left first. So we... Yeah.
THEY HUM
Stop. I'm going to do a wee in a
minute. Flipping heck. It's broke.
It's because I was a bit heavy with
the egg wash and it's just kind of
weighed it down.
George now has a huge decision
to make.
Should I fix the pie?
What the hell do I do?
Shut the door, shut the door,
shut the door, shut the door.
If he leaves his pie in the oven,
the top could fall apart.
But if he takes it out to repair it,
he'll lose vital baking time.
What... to... do.
Right, taking it out.
Feeling out of my depth.
This is pressure, man.
Come on, George.
Come on, man. Come on.
Need some leafage,
cover up the areas
that look messed up.
While George's pie heads back
into the oven, the others...
Come on, come on, come on.
..are coming out.
Go, go, go.
But the wait to unmould
isn't over just yet.
The pies must head to the freezer
to cool down.
Done. Now the filling needs to set
to avoid collapse.
It needs to chill
very, very quickly.
Now I'm nervous.
HE LAUGHS
George and Amanda have
a lot more to worry about.
Mine's got ages. Never going to get
that cool enough to turn out.
They will have no choice
but to unmould molten pies
at risk of a full scale collapse.
Do you know what I wanna do?
I'm going to do this. That's better.
Is that so they can't film it?
No, it's so I can't see it. Oh.
Do you know what? Once I take it out
the tin
I'm sure it'll be a leaking mess
in there.
Quick announcement from
Paul Hollywood in balloon form.
Bakers, you've got half hour left.
Getting it out.
Good god, why is this
so bloody tense?
The cooled pies are finally
ready to unmould.
Let's go, let's go.
Let's get it done.
But for George and Amanda,
the agonising wait continues.
I think I'm going to give it
a little bit longer.
Couple more minutes.
Right, demoulding it.
Hopefully, no soggy bottoms.
And hopefully no collapsing
terrines, either.
Crunch time.
Yes. Phew!
Good. Amazing.
SHE SIGHS Come on.
Oh, no, no, no.
There is a bit of a crack
on the back.
Mine's cracked as well.
There's cracking everywhere.
Oh, look, it's leaked.
That's some serious leakage.
Right, taking it out.
Come on, George. I'm getting it
straight in that freezer.
Amanda, mine's leaking a hell of a
lot. Look. It's fine. What's wrong
with you? It looks perfect.
Yeah, but look at the leak. So?
Bakers, ten minutes left.
Monumental leak there, man.
This needs a bloody dam.
Because the juice is still very hot,
it might just all pour out.
I feel like everybody's waiting
for my pie to fall apart.
How do you get this thing off?
It's still hot. This is dangerous.
Jesus. Leaking.
Soggy bottom.
Praying it's OK.
Fingers crossed.
No pressure.
Oh, it collapsed. Oh, no.
Oh, no. Want a hand, Amanda?
Yes, please. It's gone.
It's come off. Oh!
It's not good.
The pie's stuck on the top.
Oh, mate.
Tell me what you want me to do.
Uh, push that back in.
Just stick the knife under there
so I can get the thing back on.
This is hot, Amanda. Sorry.
Go on, there you go.
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
They can fix that. I can't watch.
I know. It's too stressful.
Quick. Don't move it, don't move it,
don't move it, don't move it.
You're going to tear it all up.
Do it slowly. That's it,
that's it, that's it.
Hold fire.
All right, I'm not going to attempt
to take it out of the bottom tray.
Risking the whole thing to collapse.
Do you know what? That's better.
It's all kind of breaking apart,
which is really sad.
Um, but I'm just hoping
if I could just cover all
the cracks I might be safe.
I'm going to lift it.
Ah. Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Slide it underneath. One, two.
Oh. It's collapsing.
Got to get this off.
Oh, no. No, it's proper broken.
Panicking now. It's a mess.
I can't watch.
All right, let's lift it off
the bottom tin. Quick.
Oh, no, no, there's a lip there,
babe, you're going to tear it.
Guys, be careful. I've left mine on.
You've left it on? Yeah. I don't
think it makes any difference now.
Ahhh!
Juice everywhere, isn't there?
Bakers, you have one minute left.
Oh, got a minute.
Repair, repair, repair.
It's like watching
open heart surgery. It is.
Which side shall I put the pigs on?
LAUGHING: This side!
This side, the good side.
Quick, quick, pigs,
pigs, pigs, pigs.
It's gonna hold my pie.
Bakers, your time is up.
Oh. Well done.
Well done for getting it out.
What a disaster.
Sorry, babe. Sorry, sorry, sorry.
It's OK.
I couldn't do anything else.
It's fine, it's not your fault.
I feel your pain, Amanda.
This is messed up.
It's judgement time for
the decorative terrine pies.
Lizzie, would you like to bring up
your Showstopper?
Well, it's certainly
unusual-looking.
It's very bold. I love the design.
I like the fish.
I think the scales look great.
Let's have a look inside, shall we?
Held together nicely and the
fish going through there. Yeah.
Little fish.
You've nearly got that spot on,
Lizzie. I love that.
Your pastry's too thick.
But I quite like the flavour.
I think it's remarkable.
The spinach and the fish,
they're not overcooked
because they've been in there
quite a long time. Thanks.
It's a really perfect owl,
isn't it?
"Ow, don't hurt me."
The design is fantastic.
Good pastry. It's firm enough,
but it's crumblier.
The cheese and all the flavours
blends well with the beef.
It looks very professional.
It's very Giuseppe.
It's excellent, Giuseppe.
I think the pastry,
you've sort of cracked it slightly
handling it out of the tin.
Juice was leaking out of there.
It looks lovely.
You get apricot, you get gherkin.
I think all the flavours work well.
But the design
is pretty uninspiring.
That was a big deal for me,
that was!
I love the vine leaves. Oh, look
at that. I think that's beautiful.
Really beautifully done.
I think the pastry tastes delicious.
But the beef has gone very, very
dry. It is a bit too dry,
but I do think you get away with it,
because you've got the horseradish.
Thank you, Jurgen.
What happened? I should have really
got it in the oven earlier
so it had time to cool down.
But when I took it, the side of it,
one side came away. Ah, right, OK.
It's very good-looking.
It's very pretty.
It's bone-dry. I think
your seasoning is pretty strong,
cos there's so many things going on
in your mouth. And you try to
identify it, but there's just
a mix of a lot of different things.
But I do like the pate. For me,
the pate is the one thing that is
a bit too strong.
Thank you, Amanda.
It's quite dramatic.
I like the two-tone pastry.
But it's underbaked,
and it's collapsed down. Yeah, yeah.
I got it in the oven late,
which was unfortunate.
My tray's under there, Paul.
It was too hot to handle!
Nice interior.
Mm.
Mm!
That sausage meat...
..I question whether it's cooked.
I probed it three times, Paul.
You did? 92 in the centre.
Right, OK.
It is a bit mushy.
It's very mushy, yeah.
It's a pity, because the bacon,
that is delicious.
That's a shame, that,
George. Thank you.
Such a beautiful cottage.
And I love all the little flowers
and the way you've decorated them
and had time to paint them.
Oh, look at that.
Wow! That's SO cool!
The colour layers are lovely.
And you've separated them
with sweet potato. Yeah.
Have you seen this here?
No...
Well done.
That curry, the way you've broken it
down into sections, and each one,
for me - the spice blend, the hot
water crust pastry, the design...
I absolutely agree, Crystelle.
It's brave to make curry pie.
It's witty, it's charming.
And often, things that are witty
and charming are not also
absolutely delicious.
And you've got the pastry perfectly.
Spot-on. Really, really good.
Well done.
Thank you so much!
A handshake on the Showstopper,
that's very rare!
I'm just in so much shock. I was
like, "Something's gone wrong."
And then out came his hand,
and I just died. I literally died.
So maybe I'm a ghost.
Maybe that's why I feel weird.
They complimented the design,
which was good.
So I'm tying to focus
on the positive,
but, yeah, I do feel like I'm in
danger. It is what it is, isn't it?
Someone has to go home,
and if it's my time to go,
then it's my time to go.
We should pay tribute
to these bakers,
because the standard has been
so good this week.
I think, coming into today, we were
talking about Amanda in a little bit
of trouble, we were talking about
Lizzie being in trouble.
But the person who did well
out of this was Lizzie,
because I think she saved herself,
to the detriment of George.
I think George and Amanda
are in a little bit of trouble.
George today, I wasn't happy at all
with that. So, Star Baker is...?
I think Star Baker is
either Giuseppe or Crystelle.
She really smashed it.
You gave her a handshake.
I know. I don't like
giving handshakes.
It hurts you, doesn't it?
It does, yeah!
But I think, ultimately,
that deserved it.
It was a bit of magic, that one.
It was. Very clever.
But I think Giuseppe's done really
well, as well. It looked amazing.
I loved his meat, though.
Are you talking about
Giuseppe's meat? I looked down at it
just as I said it. That's what it
was. We're all friends here. I know.
Well done, bakers, on another week.
It's not easy to find a Star Baker,
but the judges have done it.
This week's Star Baker is...
..Crystelle!
APPLAUSE
Thank you. God!
Oh, that means I've got the horrible
job of announcing the person
who's leaving us. This gets tougher.
It does get tougher every week,
and this has been an amazing week.
But the person who is leaving us
this week is...
..Amanda.
Thank you.
It's OK. I'm all right.
Is it all right? I knew it
cos you kept looking at me.
I mean, you've got to go
sometime, haven't you?
I didn't think when I got here
I'd get that far after seeing all
the other bakers,
but I've had such a good time.
Going to miss you.
You'll be all right, guys.
I'll see you in a few weeks.
Do you know what? I came here
to have a good time.
It's a little bit stressful here,
but it's a kind of fun stress.
Perhaps if I didn't talk so much,
I might have got a bit further.
But I enjoyed it,
so I'm glad I did what I did.
Oh, God!
I mean, that's a shock. My name
was going over and over in my head.
I was preparing myself. I was just
saying, "George. George. George."
And then they called Amanda,
and I could not believe it.
This has given me a big push
to fight for my place.
That pie!
I don't often give out handshakes
in Showstoppers,
but Crystelle deserved it.
It was perfection, in my eyes.
ON PHONE: Hello? Hi. Is everyone
there? Yeah. I got Star Baker!
SHRIEKING ON PHONE
And, guys?
Guys, guys, Paul gave me a handshake
in the Showstopper.
SHRIEKING
Oh, God! And people
wonder why I'm loud!
Next time: It's like a little
science experiment, isn't it?
..caramel week...
Nasty little thing, caramel.
..sees the bakers in sticky
situations with the Signature...
This isn't right... take on
a ten-fingered Technical...
Paul is demanding perfection.
..and struggle with an architectural
sugar Showstopper.
There's a crack. Who will
make it to the quarterfinal?
Hands up who's having
a heart attack.
And who... Where's me balls?
..will come unstuck?
Group heart attacks, everyone?
>>>>oakislandtk
www.opensubtitles.org